You know him
from his groundbreaking
blockbuster films,
Titanic, The Terminator,
the Avatar series.
His movies have won over 20 Oscars
and are some of the very highest grossing
and most expensive films of all time.
But James
Cameron is much more
than an Academy Award winning filmmaker.
He's also a scientific
explorer, engineer,
environmentalist and pioneer
of new technologies.
His innovations have descended
to the bottom of the ocean
and soared into space.
Cameron's latest documentary
series, Secrets of the Elephants,
dives into the lives
of those majestic and mammoth animals.
It will premiere on April 20,
first on National Geographic.
Cameron's commitment
to sustainability
also inspired a move to New Zealand,
where he and his wife
live on an organic farm.
We sat down recently here in New York.
James Cameron. What an honor.
It's a huge honor to be on
your show for it. Thank you.
So if you look at the four
highest grossing films
in the history of the world,
you've made three of them.
Yeah, turns out that way.
And what's extraordinary to me is,
I mean, each of these
has grossed more than $2 billion. Right.
But they do it all over the world.
They do well everywhere.
I was in India when Avatar, the new one.
The new one came out.
And India, as you
know, is consumed with Bollywood movies.
Hollywood has very small presence
historically,
except Avatar was everywhere.
Yeah.
So my question to you is,
what is it that you have found
that appeals to so many people?
The things that I care about
are trying to reach people emotionally.
But I also am very visual.
Right.
And, you know,
I get a lot of ideas from dreams
and things like that.
And I think that taps
into the subconscious
that we all kind of share,
if you believe that kind of young in
view of life.
But I also think about that
global market.
And I think I don't want to do stuff
that's just based on kind of
current mediums
and current little cultural,
you know, kind of ideas and trends.
I want to
I want to go back to sort of
classic ideas,
almost back to Greek tragedy
and things
like that, things that affect everybody.
So, for example,
the new Avatar film is about family
and bonds that we all
share in
any culture,
any religion, any language group
around the world.
Titanic, you know, about love
and sacrifice and duty,
which are things that,
for example,
you know,
maybe in Asia
you know, mean a lot to people.
So even though they had
a language barrier
to surmount, to watch the film,
it meant something to them.
You know,
so I try to just
tap into universals of human experience.
Beyond that,
I could get very specific
about visual effects
and things like that.
But I think it's that it's that universal
universal sense of who we are
as human beings.
You said you think about the world
audience, a global audience. Yes.
Do you think it helps
that you live in New Zealand?
You know, you've
got you sort of out of America?
I think it's interesting to live out.
I lived in in Los Angeles for 47 years.
I grew up in Canada before that.
Now that I live in New Zealand,
I think it's interesting
to look back on American culture
and society and politics
and so on from an outside viewpoint
and get a morning paper
that sees it in a very different way.
I think I think it's healthy,
healthy, and I think more Americans
should do that.
You know,
look into the bubble from the outside.
I mean,
I think if you think about it
in a broader sense,
that's how the Avatar movies work.
They ask us to see
through the eyes of nature,
through these blue people
back at ourselves.
And our sins against nature
that we collectively
and civilization doing.
I think maybe one in a thousand people
that goes to an Avatar movie
actually roots for the humans you know?
But we're a human audience
rooting against ourselves.
If you think about it in a strange way,
through these kind
of aspirational characters
that really represent the best of us
or the way we imagine we can be
or maybe
the way
we used to be thousands of years ago.
Yeah.
Do you think you know,
I think about this
because when you look at Asia,
which is modernizing and urbanizing
so fast
right there, in many ways
despoiling the environment even more.
And yet the movies do very well in Asia.
Yeah, I think we suffer collectively
from nature deficit disorder,
and we all need to reconnect.
And I think
because we were less urbanized
when we were kids, certainly my age
and maybe even the next
generation behind me,
we long for that sort of thing.
We had as children where we were
we were down in the grass,
we were down in the soil.
We collected birds and butterflies
and butterflies and flowers
and things like that.
We don't get that anymore.
Our lives are so urbanized.
I mean, we're here in New York right now.
It's hard to even imagine
that, you know,
and you just look out
at that technical landscape.
I think we long for it.
And so people
see something
that they that they want in their
in their dreams.
You know, there's
I think there's something
that's very kind of primitive about it
and primitive in us, atavistic right.
That we that we longed for.
And I just hope
we can reconnect with that
because, you know, we're our urban life
is devastating nature
in order to support it.
How does the subconscious work,
as best you can tell,
because you're saying
you get a lot of your ideas from dreams.
You're appealing to people
in a way
that they don't think of themselves.
I think a lot of people
as having this nature deficit disorder.
I mean, they're much going around.
Mm hmm.
But somehow, you know,
it does feel like you're
tapping into that right?
Well, I do think I do
think we have certain
innate programing
that's at a very deep level,
much lower than higher brain function.
And I think our subconscious,
when it's operating
either in the background
during the day or at night,
where it sort of takes over
is sort of
its sort of processing internally
in a way that scientists
don't really understand
dreams and the psychological purpose
that they serve.
I think they're kind of
like a generative a I you know,
I think they're making imagery
from a vast dataset.
That's our entire experience in life,
and it's just making imagery.
And then another part of our brain
is supplying a narrative
that goes along with it.
And the narrative
doesn't always make much sense you know?
But we're storytelling to ourselves
all night, all night long.
Or at least during REM sleep,
you know, and I'm not a dream actor.
I don't want to say up front
or neuroscientists,
but I think this is what's happening.
And we're trying to make sense
of the world
because we don't really remember
like a videotape.
We remember stories
like strings of beads.
You know, I went to a party, okay?
I remember where it was. That's a bead.
But you don't
you can't playback
a whole tape of the whole thing.
I'll remember this as an image,
a picture of you
and some of the topics
that we talked about.
But I won't be able to play it back
like a videotape.
And if I do playback,
you know,
a recording of it,
I'll go,
Oh, yeah,
we said that that was cool or not
or embarrass myself.
I wish I could take it back.
So.
So Billy
Joel said to me
that he gets a lot of his his music
from from dreams and that,
you know,
he he'd get up
and or even later on, he realized
it's always
the core, which was for him,
always the melody,
the harmony, not the words.
The words were later added. Interesting.
What do you explain how your dreams work?
Sounds to me.
Like for him, it's musical.
For me, it's images of images.
And, you know, so
so just a bunch of random,
sometimes very surreal images,
sometimes beautiful,
sometimes terrifying.
And I
lately been thinking that there's
a little bit of it's
not just the picture.
There's a little metadata
running underneath that
that's telling me what the picture means.
You know,
so, for example,
the Terminator was based
on a single image
of a chrome skeleton
emerging out of fire.
But the metadata said
it used
to look like a man covered in flesh
and the fire burned it away.
And so it's it's
actually a story segment.
And then you start putting
those story segments together
and then starts to turn it into a story
you want to tell to other people.
And I think storytellers
sitting around the campfire
in a cave 50,000 years ago
were doing the same thing.
And so when you get those images,
do you say to yourself,
you know,
I put I'll just mechanically do
write it down.
You would write it down
sometimes or actually draw it.
What I
you know, I remember the
you have a background is as an artist.
As a figurative artist.
Yeah. Exactly. Representational.
You know,
illustrator, I guess would be a better
a better term.
But yeah, I used to love to draw
and paint and. That's right.
I still do, but not as much because now
in my
my current
level of work in films,
the film is my painting,
the film is my art.
And I get to work with the very best,
you know, illustrators
and design artists in the world.
So I don't do it as much as I used to.
I work through them
and they're better than I ever was.
So it's okay.
But movies are a strange kind of art
because it's partly an art, but partly
there's a lot of technology.
I mean, look, right?
If you could see
there is just so many cameras around.
There's a lights and sound and
and computers.
And you you really embrace
the scientific part of all that.
Yeah, I love the I love the tech.
I love the engineering.
My mother was an artist
and my father was an engineer.
And so,
you know, it's so you've really got
genetics writ large.
You know,
I love the tech
and I love creating new tech, you know?
And I was at the
I was at the
the the advancing wave front of CG
as it started to sweep through.
And this was going back 30 years now.
But, you know,
the abyss was the first CG character
that was a soft surface character.
We, we had this kind of water
tentacle that formed faces
and then that
went on to
the liquid metal guy in Terminator two.
And from there, it progressed
to other things.
Jurassic Park,
which I didn't do Steven Spielberg yet.
But then, you know, it
built very rapidly.
We could see the future was coming,
that it would be that it would be CG.
So I like the tech side,
but it's not
the irony is not lost on me that we use
literally petabytes of storage
on all these computer monitors
and everything to make a movie
about the most naturalistic state
of the human experience, you know,
and I'll bet they're blue aliens,
but we're really celebrating
that kind of indigenous wisdom keeper
kind of kind of idea
using all this technology and
and loving it.